the washington post issues one of the
worst retractions in modern media
history
the media justified joe biden's absence
from press conferences and the vatican
shocks the world by
you know being catholic this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action
at expressvpn.com we'll get to all the
news in just one moment first a reminder
the government is now blowing out the
spending i mean to an unprecedented
degree we have never seen anything like
this in our lifetime
it is the greatest binge of spending in
the history of humanity that is going to
have some
impact on the dollar every single human
knows this who is in the know we all
know
that they're going to blow out the
dollar it is just a question of when
this is why you should be diversified at
least a little bit
into precious metals this is why you
should be talking to my friends over at
birch gold group i buy my gold from
birch gold and so do you i'm excited
because birch gold has now passed a
major milestone 10
000 customers that's 10 000 people who
have a plan against radical leftist
policies driving up our national debt
and devaluing the dollar if you've been
waiting to call birch gold to convert an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira backed
by gold and silver
now would be the time through april 30th
on qualifying purchases when you
purchase precious metals with birch gold
they will send you
a free home safe we've given away books
we've given away silver this
is their biggest giveaway ever text ben
to 474747 for your free information kit
on precious metals ira or to speak with
a birch gold representative today with
ten thousand customers they have an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews
they can help you as well text ben to 47
47 47 for your free safe
with purchase again text ben 247 47 47
to talk with my friends over at birch
gold now is a great time to diversify
away from the american dollar
and into something like precious metals
go check out my friends at birch gold
texpens who 47
47 47 alrighty so the washington post
has now be clowned itself in epic
fashion
the washington post is an
extraordinarily biased source it has
been extraordinarily by a source
for many many years but i have to say
this may be the worst major media
correction i have ever seen in my life
it's pretty astonishing so you'll recall
that way back
in december the washington post reported
a call
the call was supposed to be between
president trump
and a georgia investigator okay and that
georgia investigator
he apparently told according to the
washington post that this georgia
investigator would be quote
a national hero if they found the fraud
he apparently encouraged this georgia
investigator to quote unquote find the
fraud and said they would be a national
hero
if they did so okay now
now it turns out that those quotes were
entirely fabricated like top to bottom
made up according to the washington post
correction quote
two months after publication of this
story the georgia secretary of state
released an audio recording of president
donald trump's december phone call with
the state's top elections investigator
the recording revealed that the post
misquoted trump's comments on the call
based on information provided by a
source so in other words they talked to
a single
source who was supposedly privileged to
the phone call that person made
up quotes the washington post simply
quoted that source
without any sort of actual sourcing and
then when the phone call broke
as in like a couple of months after the
story when it broke in
february march then it turned out none
of this was on the phone call and the
washington post had to retract
basically the center of the story now
this is a separate phone call from the
one that happened that we all heard the
audio of president trump and brad
raffensberger the georgia secretary of
state
at the time i said it was easy to
mischaracterize that conversation as
trump
telling raffensberger that he needed to
find votes somewhere that were
fraudulent it was the opposite
right what he was saying in that phone
call was he believed i think baselessly
that there were a bunch of
votes in georgia that were improper and
that raffensburger was ignoring that
evidence and he was encouraging to go
find the evidence that trump thought
existed
but you could read it the other way but
something that certainly never happened
that we know at this point is that trump
never said that you would be a quote
unquote national hero
if you find the fraud and didn't tell
the investigator to find the fraud or
say
that she would be a quote national hero
if she did so instead trump urged the
investigator to scrutinize ballots in
fulton county georgia asserting she
would find dishonesty there he also told
her she had the most important job
in the country right now the headline
and text of the post report have now
been corrected to remove quotes
misattributed to trump the newspaper
says
i mean how dangerous that is seriously
like as a matter of journalism you know
how crazy it is that you had quotes in a
headline
that were attributed to the president of
the united states based on a single
unnamed source
and it turns out that it was just a lie
it was just made up
the correction comes days after the wall
street journal obtained audio of the
december call between trump and the
investigator
trump told francis watson the chief
investigator of the georgia secretary of
state's office quote when the right
answer comes out you'll be praised
watson reportedly responded i can assure
you that our team and the georgia bureau
of investigation we are only interested
in the truth and finding information
based on the facts
the original post report according to
the hill shook the political world just
days after the january 5th runoff
elections in georgia
a contest both republican senators lost
giving democrats the majority
in the upper chamber the original post
report was covered widely by many media
outlets including the hill which has
also updated its report
on the trump call you know here is the
thing that's amazing
you will you'll remember that there were
other outlets that then
confirmed the posts reporting so what
happened is the post reported stuff that
wasn't true
and then it turns out that they had to
walk that back but at the time
after the post reported that trump had
said find the fraud and you'll be a
national hero if you do so
at the time there were other outlets
that confirmed the reporting
and that led people who watch the media
to say okay well if you have a bunch of
outlets that are now confirming the same
story well now
you can pretty much guarantee that the
story is true except what if that's not
true
what if the way that the media now do
business when there is a republican
president
is they find a anonymous source that
anonymous source then tells their story
to the washington post
and then that same exact anonymous
source goes over to cbs news
and says that exact same untrue story
and then cbs news says based on our
source we can also confirm that we have
heard that the story is true
so basically you now have a single
source who is dictating news to a wide
variety of mainstream
media outlets and because these
mainstream media outlets are granting
these people the privilege of speaking
on background meaning anonymously this
means there is no way to confirm
whether you have more than one source
confirming the story is true right
normally
when you have the washington post make a
report and then the new york times
confirms that report
the assumption is that there is one
source for the new york times and one
source for the washington post
and so multiple sources have now doubled
right double sourcing is the way that
journalism is supposed to work you're
supposed to have two sources who
corroborate or report not just
one okay but the way that the media now
work is one anonymous source goes to the
washington post and says something
that's untrue
that same person because they've now
been quoted anonymously in the
washington post
the same person now goes to the new york
times tells the exact same story
and the new york times says we can
confirm the washington post reporting
but can you because apparently you're
now like how many stories have been
laundered
into multiple outlets by one person
i'm sure this has happened multiple
times this happened one time it happened
many times according to
the daily wire real clear investigation
senior writer mark hemingway says this
kind of mistake is beyond serious
there's zero accountability in major
corporate media yet they continually
insist
they're the ones holding the line on the
truth and always remember what should
scare you about the media is what
doesn't get exposed
note the headline on the post-follow-up
story it's sort of maliciously anodyne
recording reviews reveals details of
trump call to georgia's chief elections
investigator
it's not trump's remarks grossly
misrepresented across media because we
incredulously fall for political ops
mary katherine hamm of cnn she says that
somebody should lose their job
she said so they made up quotes wasn't
the actual f the header for the story
could be a little clearer like our bad
we made fake news that led the national
news for weeks and this audio proves it
for those in my timeline asking if it
really matters because trump is bad
anyway
yes it really matters quotes being
correct matters a lot
don't you see that's the issue if a
reporter is so dead sure that quote
trump bad anyway he is less inclined to
question
or vet his own stories and don't give me
the corrections are an example of the
system working stuff
sometimes they are here they're coming
in three months later when they are
outed by a recording and the correction
and new story are designed to downplay
as much as possible
not blair as loudly as the original
again it's a pretty amazing thing so
they directly misattributed quotes they
didn't paraphrase right they put it in
quotation marks they said trump said x
trump never said x they did it based on
anonymous sourcing and then
they laundered that into multiple media
outlets and this was
by the way this was quoted in the
impeachment papers for trump the second
time around
that report was quoted in the
impeachment papers and it was charge 10
in the impeachment papers okay that's
pretty unbelievable so they laundered
a false piece of news into an
impeachment and then they wonder why we
don't trust them then they wonder why
the credibility of the media is on edge
it also demonstrates full scale that the
fact-checking media are just garbage
it shows that the fact-checking media
are willing to cover for pretty much
anything so long as it comes from one of
their buddies because the way that this
works
is that if you are a member of the
establishment approved media you can say
anything
and your fact-checking buddies will
cover up for you but if you're a member
of the non-establishment media
then they will come after you with a
pickaxe for saying something that is
true but they disagree with
it really is an impressive show here the
fact again
that the washington post blew this story
so badly
and the fact that the entire media are
now rushing to the defense of the
washington post
should tell you something it should tell
you something
it's it is pretty amazing again the
original washington post story
did break i believe on january january
6th
is when it originally broke or i'm sorry
the the the original news was was broken
before january 6th
and january 5th was before the georgia
runoff i believe so may have had an
impact on an incredibly tight georgia
runoff election
that's not exactly a shocker glenn
kessler the washington post fact checker
he said the washington post reporting on
trump's call to the georgia secretary of
state
undisputed as the audio tape was
obtained from the start was the article
cited in the impeachment article trump
naturally pretends otherwise
but that's not actually true actually
they they reveal
they actually refer to i believe both
stories
so impressive showing by the meat but
this is what our media are now
cnn spends all day just covering fox
news
that's all the media do the media cover
people in conservative news
and they report false stories and they
launder the false stories through
multiple media outlets and then
they give themselves nice fact checks
very very convenient stuff
for our mainstream media who are doing
an excellent job journalism
because this is what they do and again
the false news always rockets around
earth faster than the real news
you wonder why president trump had a lot
of ground to cover
he had such fertile ground when he would
talk about fake news the answer is
because we in the conservative community
have known for decades that the media do
this kind of crap
okay this goes well back before bernard
goldberg put out the book bias in the
early 2000s
i remember my parents cancelling their
subscriptions to los angeles times in
the mid 90s
over the los angeles times running a
picture of a of a
supposedly palestinian man supposedly
being beaten by an israeli soldier on
their front page
the caption was false it turned out that
it was a man attempting to escape
palestinian rock throwers and an israeli
soldier shouting at the people trying to
throw rocks at the guy
the fake news has been a thing for quite
a while and all the mistakes are in one
direction when is the last time they
made a mistake
in the direction of conservatives can
you name one
i mean literally one can you name a
mistake that has been made in the
direction of republicans
the answer of course is no and these
kind of stories happen regularly
people lose their jobs over this kind of
stuff and we've talked on this program
in the past several weeks
about the about the media simply taking
comments by particular people and then
deliberately misinterpreting them to get
them fired there's an entire washington
post story
that came on the heels of a georgetown
professor being fired for saying
something not racist and the entire
angle of the story is that it was racist
there are a couple of types of bias that
the media can go through one is
selection bias what they cover and what
they don't
they won't cover andrew cuomo being a
corrupt tool bag until a couple of
months after the election then they'll
start covering it so selection bias is
one thing
and then there is the way they cover
stories right the angle of the story
that is another area of bias
and then the third is the worst kind of
bias and that is where they will just
believe whatever confirms their priors
and then they will just report that
credit credulously out and then later if
they get it wrong they'll walk it back
let's not pretend that these folks have
any stake in the in the objective truth
when i say these folks don't mean
everybody in the media but there are
enough of them that it is indicative of
a broader problem in the media they
refuse
to face up to it's pretty incredible
another perfect example of the media
simply laundering a story into a
non-story
or rather laundering a non-story into a
story so peter pishki
is a columnist for the post-millennial
he has a piece today about a doctor
who's basically been run
railroaded out of the american medical
association here is what he says until
last week dr edward livingston was a
celebrated academic
known for his compassion and for being a
wise hand of difficult topics he was the
deputy editor of jama
the ama's scientific and scholarly arm
and host of its successful jama clinical
reviews podcast
now he's persona non grata does anyone
care about the truth when a juicy
narrative is afoot will we burn
everything down to get to the sin of
racism even when none occurred
if you google livingston's name you'll
find such damning headlines like
jama post podcast on structural racism
here is the backlash
gemma apologizes and deletes tweet the
question racism and medicine marketwatch
no physician is racist twitter calls
foul on jama podcast med page today and
dozens more like it
facing such an impossibly overwhelming
force the panicking ama fired livingston
memory hold
an episode of a podcast and announced a
formal investigation
as the finishing touch ama ceo dr james
madera declared what amounts to the ama
pledging itself to anti-racism is
popularized by ebermex candy
so what exactly happened here well dr
livingston is innocent of racism
he himself is in adherence of what the
new left calls anti-racism i know
because i did what the media wouldn't my
homework
whether it be out of laziness or
purposeful manipulation publications
like medscape business insider forbes
the hill and the root
all condemned livingston not a one
bothered to even provide a copy or
transcript of the offending audio
livingston's detractors so-called proof
is a singular bad podcast alert tweet
and some uncontextualized lines of
dialogue the declarative shout for
racism is a tweet the kind of which an
intern might write or post as mangled
copy from show notes which was sent out
by the jama twitter handle it read
no physician is racist so how can there
be structural racism in healthcare an
explanation of the idea by doctors four
doctors in this user-friendly podcast
from the date
the great dr katz nych and ehl jama
the odds that a deputy editor of the one
of the most influential journals of
medicine wrote his own podcast alert is
an absurdity
the other evidence against livingston
quotes devoid of context from the
podcast episode
this episode featured public health
expert dr mitch cass ceo of nyc health
plus hospitals
in what was the fourth part of a series
dedicated to fighting racism in medicine
of which livingston was a participant
here is the line shared by the media to
justify indignation quote
structural racism is an unfortunate term
personally i think taking racism out of
the conversation will help
many of us are offended by the concept
that we are racist
you don't need a degree from a j school
to see that the media are cherry-picking
this comment
according to anti-racists structural
racism is what happens when parts of
society get ordered in such a way that
it disproportionately hurts minorities
or folks like me the disabled
the media wants you to believe that dr
livingston a jewish descendant of
immigrants has a closeted structural
racism denier that is just
not true here is the full context of the
closing remarks
quote structural racism is an
unfortunate term to describe a very real
problem
there are structural problems in our
society there are neighborhoods that are
impoverished the quality of life is poor
in those areas because we may put
factories in them or have major
thoroughfares that travel through them
but we strive to have a society that's
more equal et cetera et cetera et cetera
okay so this doctrine never denied that
there is structural racism
by the way the the notion of structural
racism
is widely open to interpretation the
basic idea that if there is some sort of
in equality of outcome that this means
the system is itself racist
is a logical absurdity it's not real but
that's not even what this doctor is
saying this doctor is a
left-wing adherent he's an anti-racist
it didn't matter he lost
his job with jama anyway because again
the lie matters more than the truth so
long as there is somebody to get today
so long as there is somebody you can
take out of context today the media will
just do it all the way from
a random doctor to the president of the
united states because they are
all in the tank these networks are in
the tank these newspapers are in the
tank
you cannot trust them and then because
you can't trust them their next move is
to shut down
any other place you can get news which
is why you have columnists for the
washington post
clubbing social media saying they
shouldn't allow places like my place
daily wire to have any traffic
it's why you have people in the
mainstream media going after sub stack
so individual journalists can't actually
write what they want to write
they must maintain the monopoly on their
faux version of the truth
okay in just a second we'll get to more
on their faux version of the truth
because the bias is so eminently obvious
first a lot is happening at your front
door these days you have a lot of
packages delivered
and as kovid begins to wane you're
starting to see your friends and your
family more often in compliance with cdc
guidelines and all of that well here's
the thing you need to know what's
happening
at your house on any given day and at
any time of the day
this is why you need ring devices on
your home when we moved from la to
florida the first thing my wife said is
let's get the ring devices on the house
and thus we have now is the perfect time
to upgrade your doorstep
with a ring video doorbell with ring you
can see and speak to whoever is at the
door from anywhere right on your phone
you're never going to miss a visitor
whether it's your neighbor your dinner
your groceries
you can keep those packages and delivery
safe with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell if somebody stops by or
something is going on ring will just let
you know
i love having that ring video doorbell
i've actually added ring security
cameras around the house as well because
i have three children
who are constantly trying to run into
things i only have one pair of eyes
ring helps me keep eyes on everything
going on at my house they can do the
same for you right now
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ring.com it comes with ring video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience
go to ring.com again that is ring.com
ben okay so when i say that the media
have a bias um
i mean that their bias is extraordinary
joe biden
president house plant he's just there to
hide the water stand the water stand is
the radical policy
president house plans is there to
provide a moderate face but to be barely
alive and never talk to the media and
avoid all questions
and for the media to cheer this because
remember the trump administration was
dishonest
and obstructionist they didn't provide
the media with the information they
needed
the biden administration doesn't do
press conferences and lies regularly
but the media cheer them on are you
noticing why might it have something to
do with the fact that the media love
joe biden's policies and they're big
fans
thus you have this tweet from politico
honestly like
this is a north korean style tweet quote
two and a half months in
president biden has surprised some of
his former colleagues and allies with a
largely gaff-free white house debut
after a lifetime of verbal stumbles wow
gaff free guys
did you know that joe biden's been
gaffery weird because every time he
talks i play a gap of his on the show
every single time without fail the
president of the united states cannot
get through three sentences without
stumbling
he cannot it is a physical impossibility
for him at this point he is in a state
of decline it is sad to say and frankly
it's bad for him it's bad for the
country
i wish it weren't true i wish you were
fully himself and fully and fully
healthy but he clearly is not
okay but the media are just going to
pretend that he is gaff free
so not only is he gaff free and stumble
free they're like
wow i mean it's been an incredible you
know why because they are hiding him in
the basement gang he hasn't done a press
conference he hasn't answered an
unfriendly question since january 20th
by my calendar it is now march 16th
so it has been almost two full months
since he took office
and he has not taken an unfriendly
question yet instead he takes questions
like
what flavor of ice cream do you like and
how are those white house dogs doing
it's unbelievable and the media are
treating this as though he's just good
at this he's not good at this you guys
are just bad at this
it's not that joe biden is good at his
job it's that you guys are crap at your
job
according to ed morrissey at hot air he
says wake me when more than one person
asks questions at a time and when jill
biden isn't acting as joe's wingman
okay my prediction this will not age
well this political tweet it shouldn't
even age at all at least not among the
white house press corps who might be
wondering when biden's absence from the
briefing room will finally get some
notice from their colleagues in the
media
there's been a curious lack of pressure
from media outlets over access to biden
even more so from media outlets that
adopted slogans like democracy dies in
darkness during the previous
administration
what exactly does largely gaff free mean
is that anything like praising his
spouse for being frequently faithful
largely gaff free politico's actual
write-up apparently is a little bit
better than the tweet but not by much
they say joe biden disciplined messenger
disciplined messenger
okay he just loses the thread in the
middle of questions
he says things that make no sense they
literally shut down white house feed so
he doesn't answer questions
but he's gaff free guys not only that
you have full articles from the
washington post
your source for establishment news a
full article in the washington post
defending joe biden for not doing press
conferences the title quote
biden is due for a news conference but
they can be risky oh
can they tell me more media specialist
they can be risky guys who knew you know
what the solution to that is
never have a press conference but if
you're republican you never have a press
conference you're super bad
but if you're joe biden you know it's
understandable because press conferences
can be risky
president biden will hold his first
formal news conference before april's
fool's day the white house says
even if he held one today it would be
the latest any new commander-in-chief
has faced a formal q a session with the
press corps in a century
his aides know the delay doesn't
resonate much outside the beltway on
sunday white house chief of staff ron
clain
retweeted a former hillary clinton
advisor's mocking point then not doing a
press conference won't cost biden
for 20 years presidential aides have
been telling me that news conferences
are high risk and low reward
a setting in which reporters largely set
the agenda questions can come out of
left field
and one revealing comment from a step
from the president can define the
exchange
but that's just it you know he probably
should but like the first the
the entire article is about how it makes
perfect sense why joe biden
is not doing press conferences yes we
know because then he doesn't have to ask
her questions about his garbage policy
we understand and by the way the policy
is in fact garbage
so instead joe biden is just doing what
joe biden does he just goes directly to
the cameras
okay so joe biden is now going to be
taking a victory lap on coveted relief
he is not going to be
running around taking questions from the
press he's not going to do any sort
of interview in which difficult
questions are asked he'll get softballs
from george stephanopoulos he's now
scheduled to sit down with george
stephanopoulos which is essentially like
scheduling
a lie down with your masseuse george
stephanopoulos former hillary clinton
aide into
again it is just it will never cease to
be a source of amazement to me that
george stephanopoulos is somehow
considered
an objective source of news when he was
the chief of staff for hillary and bill
clinton this makes is unbelievable to me
it's the equivalent of
what if we just made karl rove a news
anchor seriously what if we just made
jared kushner a news anchor
like what in the world are you talking
about are you insane
but george stephanopoulos over abc news
like
what in the world but he's gonna sit
down with joe biden i prom it'll
probably be super hard hitting
i mean i assume that the questions will
be along the lines of so joe how are the
dogs doing
and also joe just how much help are
americans going to get from you
it'll be stuff like that joe biden
meanwhile taking a very very slow
victory lap on covet relief pretending
that all of this spending was necessary
it absolutely was not
and again the the democratic economic
program
all the things that people tend to think
of as the bugs are the features they
want to blow out the spending
they want to devalue the currency they
want to raise taxes these are all part
and parcel of a broader plan to claim
that capitalism is failing because the
more you intervene with capitalism the
more capitalism has a tough time and
then when things fail
you get more government interventionism
when you blow out the currency the way
they are doing right now when you blow
out the spending
this is not going to alleviate income
inequality it's going to exacerbate
income inequality because
the income inequality can only be
changed by people at the bottom
getting richer that only happens when
they get better jobs over the course of
time
not by simply signing people checks the
way that joe biden apparently thinks
poverty is cured
is with helicopter cash this has never
been true any time in human history
but here's joe biden taking a very slow
victory lap with a couple of uh
with a couple of metamucil breaks over
the next 10 days
we'll reach two goals two giant goals
the first is 100 million shots in
people's arms
will have been completed within the next
10 days and 100 million
checks in people's pockets in the next
hundred days
shots and arms and money in pockets
that's important the american rescue
plan is already doing
what it was designed to do make a
difference in people's everyday
lives we're just getting started you're
just getting started you just blew it
out for two trillion dollars
only 800 billion dollars of which was
even designed to go directly to
americans and the vast majority of those
americans still have jobs and are
earning incomes and still have savings
from the last go-around
again the unemployment rate in the
united states right now is about six
percent
it is not 20 it is not 30 it is not 40
in states that are open the unemployment
rate is 3 percent
now joe biden is living off the benefit
of the fact that there's going to be a
natural economic recovery here simply as
people go back to work this is the most
artificial economic depression
in the history of the american of the
american state
not close right i mean we we were going
great guns we had an unemployment rate
that was down to about three percent
which is effectively full employment
and the raise and the wages were rising
we had more open jobs than people
seeking the jobs
so the wages were rising and then covet
hit
and it artificially tanked the economy
because all the governments forced
everybody to stay out of their jobs
so that means that when everybody goes
back to their job there will be a vast
recovery
i mean joe biden is one lucky son of a
gun because number one he can be not
alive and receive the plotted to the
media
number two the economy is going to go
grey guns simply by dint to the fact
that it was before then there was an
artificial drop
and now the artificial drop is ending
this is why goldman sachs predicts that
the
the gold that the economy is going to be
growing at eight percent for 2021.
axio says if goldman's forecast is
correct it would mark the largest
economic expansion for the us
in generations not only would eight
percent annual growth denote a
stupendous turnaround from the
coronavirus pandemic it would
significantly outpace the firm's growth
expectations for the us as recently as
late to 2020.
according to goldman we have raised our
gdp forecast to reflect the latest
fiscal policy news and now expect 8
growth in 2021 and an unemployment rate
of four percent at the end of 2021
the lowest among consensus forecasts
that falls to 3.5 percent in 2022 and
3.2
in 2023 but we expect inflation dynamics
to mirror those last cycle and therefore
expect this forecast to translate to
only 2.1
core pce inflation in 2023 okay well
what they are saying is that inflation
is not going to spike over the course of
the next couple of years because the
economy is going to be super heated
but what happens by 2024 at a certain
point you have to pay for this stuff and
this is what joe biden knows
so what is his plan to pay for this
stuff to avoid inflation as inflation
starts to rise
what you're going to see joe biden push
for is higher taxation
that is the other end so joe biden gets
exactly what he wants he's a high tax
high spend
this is what he wants the taxation is a
feature not a bug remember the
democratic party
wants to tax you it is not that they tax
you because they need the money to do
good things
they want to tax you i'll never forget
in 2008
barack obama being asked on a democratic
primary stage whether
he would raise the capital gains tax
even if it resulted in less tax revenue
for the government
because one of the things about tax
revenue is that a growing economy
produces more tax revenue and a
shrinking economy produces less tax
revenue so if tax policy creates a
shrinking economy
would you still want higher taxes on
capital gains
and barack obama's answer was yes for
purposes of fairness
democrats want higher taxes because they
think that the government is good and
you are stupid
they think that the government should
sign you checks and you should stay home
they think that you can't make decisions
about your own life
whether it is mass scoring or economic
spending raising taxes
is something they want and by the way if
you believe that their taxes
are going to stop at four hundred
thousand dollars if you make over 400
a year they'll raise taxes but if you
make below they won't that's a lie
they're gonna raise taxes in a variety
of areas that hit people in the middle
of the income spectrum because the kind
of spending they are doing right now
requires it there is no way around it
you cannot have
european styles of living without
european style taxation
and the highest tax brackets in places
like scandinavia kick
in when you're making about 60 or 65 000
bucks a year not when you're making 400
a year plus you're going to now
experience what we call bracket creep so
it is easy to say
when you have for that you know if you
make over 400 000 a year then you're
going to get increased taxation but what
happens as inflation starts to kick in
what happens as people start to inflate
value of the or deflate the value of the
us dollar and what brought you a bagel
yesterday
is half the money that would cost you to
buy a bagel today
what happens when your wage rises simply
to compensate for the rising prices of
goods and services
what happens then what happens when four
hundred thousand dollars today is
actually the equivalent of two hundred
thousand dollars five years ago
you get bracket creep in other words you
don't even have to change the absolute
number
all you have to do is wait for inflation
to catch up and push people into
quote unquote higher income brackets
even though they can't buy more for
their money
so what is joe biden planning he's
planning a massive tax expansion we'll
get to that in just
one second first let us talk about your
sleep quality so
i've been sleeping a lot better thank
god my baby has finally been sleeping
through the night
and one of the reasons that i've really
been enjoying it is because i have my
helix sleep mattress helix sleep they've
got a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete
they match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses that are
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting these
unboxing videos from so many of you who
also found the helix mattress of your
dreams if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 and by gq
and wired magazine just head on over to
helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've even
got a 10-year warranty you have to try
out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks on all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com go check
them out right now helixsleep.com the
bed's great
we have one we have one of these
mattresses helix is offering up to 200
bucks
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com go check them out
right now alrighty so let's biden's tax
plans in just one second first we've
been talking about it for a week now
this is where it gets really awesome
this friday march 19th the premiere
of candace that's daily wire's new talk
show hosted by conservative lightning
rod candace owns
it's no secret that candace has ruffled
some feathers along the course of her
career i mean
just in the last couple of months she's
been in fights with cardi b
and uh and with harry styles now you're
going to see candace like never before
in her new show
candace shows her personal side to her
guests and her live audience while she
tackles the big political and cultural
topics of the week with her signature
blend of humor and insight don't forget
canada starts this friday march 19th
will be exclusive to the daily wire if
you aren't a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
that is dailywire.com
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden is now pushing
massive at tax hikes according to
bloomberg
joe biden is planning the first major
federal tax hike since 1993 to help pay
for the long-term economic program
designed
as a follow-up to his pandemic relief
bill so that was fun right he gave you
free money accepted ain't free because
there ain't no such thing
as free money at a certain point that
money has to come from somewhere there
are only three places that you can get
money
when you spend money like this one in
the bond market you sell bonds you take
that money and you hand that to
americans
there's only one problem with that the
bond market is going to go under if you
keep doing this over and over and you
blow out the debt so that nobody thinks
they're going to get paid back with a
dollar that is of the same value as the
dollar they are paying you today for the
bond
two you inflate the currency by just
printing dollars that is the second step
three you tax the crap out of americans
none of these three things are good
which is why you should really consider
before you decide to spend trillions of
dollars that do not exist
well here's the thing again joe biden
wants the taxes democrats love the taxes
the taxes are their friend
because they get to then claim that they
are punishing the rich this is a class
warfare point
it is not about the efficiency and
efficacy of america's economy this is an
economy that is producing without tax
hikes
a three percent unemployment rate okay
and your
solution is to take all those job
creators and tax the living crap out of
them
what do you think they're gonna do if
you tax economic activity
why would i at a certain point i'm going
to either move to avoid taxes right i
just
i'm not going to pretend i didn't do
that with california i personally took
my family and left california
in large measure because of their
extraordinary income tax rates
i didn't feel like paying on top an
additional 13 to 15
of my income to the garbage state of
california i didn't feel like doing that
so people will find ways to not do that
okay and if you raise the capital gains
tax you know what people will just take
that money and they will put it
into savings they just will not spend
they will take that money off the market
and they will put it on the sidelines
trillions of dollars sat on the
sidelines during the obama
administration for precisely this
purpose
the minute that donald trump took office
a lot of that money came off the
sidelines which is one of the reasons
why you saw this economic boon
okay right now joe biden is living off
the fact that there is again this
artificial economic
expansion that comes in the wake of an
extraordinary artificial economic
depression
so he doesn't actually have to feel the
impact of his own bad economic policy
and he's counting on that he's counting
on you not noticing because again
if the economic growth rates are seven
percent as opposed to eight percent
that's a pretty big difference actually
but you're not going to feel it because
the expansion is so great
so it's all fun and games as long as it
lasts but then
it doesn't last and then there are
consequences to this kind of crap
for the biden administration the plan
changes are an opportunity not just to
fund key initiatives like infrastructure
climate and expanded help for poorer
americans but also to address what
democrats argue are inequities in the
tax system itself by the way again
whenever you hear people say that people
at the top aren't paying their fair
share
what would be the fair share the top one
percent of income earners in the united
states pay something like thirty percent
of all tax revenue through income tax to
the federal government
the top fifty percent pay one hundred
percent the top 10 percent pay something
like 80
of all taxes in the united states so
no you're right it's not fair it's not
fair because you know it would actually
be fair a flat tax rate
i speak of someone who has paid taxes in
nearly every income bracket
in american life and i've earned a very
middle-class income before and paid the
tax bracket and i've paid the top tax
bracket as well
and let me tell you i'm paying a lot
more in tax by percentage now than i
ever was making
sixty thousand dollars a year okay it is
it is
amazing to me that people continue to
maintain the absolute fiction that
people at the top are not paying their
way it's just not true
all net taxes in the united states are
paid by the wealthy all
not some at all they are paid by the
wealthy net taxes are
in the taxes that you pay minus the
government benefits that you receive
because if you're at the top of the
income spectrum
you receive no government benefits
according to sarah bianchi head of the
us public policy at evercore isi
his whole outlook has always been that
americans believe tax policy needs to be
fair
fair see this is the beautiful thing
about the mush forward fair fair just
means whatever joe biden says it means
today
that's what fair means it's not about
efficiency it doesn't have a measurable
outcome
it's just about fair so all of this
is not really about helping the economy
so much is it is it about the the ruse
of using the government to cram down a
version of fairness on the american
public that comes straight from joe
biden's adult brain
wonderful meanwhile it is amazing people
want the government to control your life
have you seen the government lately
and when you see kamala harris up at the
at the podium saying we're from the
government we're here to help when was
the last time the government did a great
job with something like a fantastic job
okay the reality is that even the
vaccine programs those vaccines were
developed by private industry
they're being largely distributed by
private industry and places like publix
or cvs
they're being distributed in doctor's
offices if they are being distributed by
an efficient government that's only
because of state governments when's the
last time the federal government did
something you thought wow that was
efficient
that was amazing i'm so glad they did
that and i don't mean just
making up money and giving it to you
because it's not an actual task
that's not something that they actually
administer well
speaking of things they don't administer
well joe biden continues to ignore
the growing threat on the border
according to the washington post biden
faces growing political threat from
border up people again every headline
from the washington post
is how is it hurting joe's feelings how
is the news hurting adult joe's feelings
today
sean sullivan and nick miroff writing
representative henry kweller a moderate
texas democrat whose district hugs the
border with mexico isn't happy
with how president biden's team has
responded to the surge of migrants
trying to enter the united states
his people need to do a better job of
listening to those of us who have done
this before he said monday
representative mccarthy he says this is
worse than a crisis
here's kevin mccarthy the house minority
leader
it's worse than a crisis i thought i
would see a crisis but this is
really a human heartbreak we have a
brand new facility to care for these
children
they built it beyond capacity thinking
they would never reach it
today they just set the anniversary that
they broke capacity more than a thousand
and forty children and it's only growing
every day how many children didn't make
it how much is human trafficking
being increased by what's happening and
it all started with these presidential
policies
okay he happens to be correct about this
according to the washington post biden
is now facing fire
from a variety of places on the
political spectrum centrist democrats
are afraid that his board policy is
going to
turn the 2022 election against them
liberals and immigration activists are
upset because of how migrants are being
treated because they just want people
let into the country
willy-nilly republicans of course are
pouncing lots of pouncing
the washington post is deeply worried
about the political impact on joe biden
of all of this
they say it's not clear that voters are
going to see it how biden sees it trump
demonstrated that immigration can be an
explosive issue that upends the
political landscape
suggesting it could be a real threat to
a president who's otherwise coasting on
high approval ratings and the dilemma is
greater
because so many crossing the border are
minors
the president is receiving high marks
from most americans for his efforts to
curtail covet including a sweeping 1.9
trillion dollar relief bill
that has left republicans scrambling to
find a potent issue as they seek to
retake the house
and senate in 2022 many republicans
believe immigration may be that topic as
the republican pouncing that's the
problem
not the thousands of kids being held in
cages by the way immigrant teens are now
going to be held at the dallas
convention
center this is how bad things have
gotten at the border the us government
plans to house up to 3 000 immigrant
teenagers at a convention center in
downtown dallas as it struggles to find
space for the surge of migrant children
at the border who have strained the
immigration system just two months into
joe biden's presidency american
authorities encountered people crossing
the border without legal status more
than 100
000 times in february that is a level
higher than all but four months of
donald trump's presidency
this of course is a challenge for
president joe biden
and his credibility which of course is
the big thing we have to worry about
biden we shouldn't worry about the
policy just worry about biden
these days speaking of which if you
think that this white house is not
radical enough they're not war with the
popes that's exciting stuff
so the white house has announced that
they are at odds with the catholic
church
it is always a source of great
bemusement and amusement to me when the
media find out that the catholic church
believes catholic things
this is one of my favorites so every so
often the media will have a headline
and the headline will be something like
catholic church
catholic church still against same-sex
marriage right like like they have been
for you know two thousand years
since you know like the gospels i mean
shocking
now i it actually here's the thing it
actually is shocking because so many
religious institutions have just caved
and decided they don't give a damn about
anything the bible says anymore that
basically all church is supposed to be
is some warmed over pizza a guy playing
the guitar and some vague chant
about spirituality and finding her bliss
basically churches have turned into
1960s
yoga sessions but it turns out that
catholic church one of the historic
institutions of of western civilization
it still has a doctrine that doctrine
actually exists
on abortion and same-sex marriage and i
understand that they're surprised
because they think that pope francis
after having knocked over the catholic
church's position on capitalism
under pope john paul ii and the catholic
church's position
on economics and individual freedom
under under benedict they've decided
basically to embrace liberation theology
under under pope francis who's a very
very left-wing pope
i know that they're still shocked to
learn that pope francis you know still
being catholic
actually doesn't believe in abortion on
demand and thinks it's a grave crime and
also doesn't believe in same-sex
marriage
but it is still a source of amusement to
me that the entire media is going to be
shocked by this
and they are they're shocked now here's
the reality they're not shocked
their goal is to make institutions like
the catholic church defunct
that has been their goal for quite a
while either hijack an institution or
destroy it this is the way that the
modern american
left and the international left works
all institutions must either be hijacked
or destroyed
if you can't destroy the military you
hijack the military by turning it woke
and then having
members of the military march to marjory
taylor green's office
because she said that guam was a foreign
country idiotically so people went to
her office from the military to show
that guam
is actually a u.s territory like i have
no idea
why that is necessary irrelevant you
know you might want to face up to china
at some point guys but every institution
must be turned and so the catholic
church must be turned or destroyed
this by the way is one of the reasons
why the media went so hard after the
catholic church in the wake of what was
a monstrous and egregious
pedophilia scandal inside the catholic
church two things can be true at once
one that was a monstrous cover-up by the
catholic church for which
the repercussions still have not been
fully paid and two
the kind of child abuse that you saw in
the catholic church has been happening
in american public schools for
generations and nobody talks about it
because
frankly the left loves the public
schools so two things can be true at
once right you never hear about the
scandal
of kids being abused in public schools
because you're not allowed to talk about
that
but they will focus all their ire on the
catholic church again
the the differential treatment is the
critique not that people should get off
scot-free for the mistreatment of
children god forbid
okay but the point here is that for the
media the catholic church is an enemy
and to pretend it's anything but
is ridiculous they will occasionally say
nice things about pope francis when pope
francis mirrors their garbage about
climate change
and how we need a redistributionist
global economic policy but
the minute the pope francis actually
cites things that have you know
something to do with catholic doctrine
as opposed to fringe stuff that the
bible really doesn't talk about
then they get all uptight so the white
house has now announced that joe biden
is at odds
with the pope on same-sex unions because
the pope came out and said that the
catholic church cannot bless same-sex
unions again
a position that has not changed for
several thousand years does not arise
from animus
arises from natural law theology natural
law theology which has been
a major part of church thought since
thomas aquinas
and really their proto-roots of natural
law theology even before that
the basic idea of natural law theology
is that god created the universe in a
certain way
that certain way gives us clues as to
what human behavior should look like
and the catholic church's stance on
same-sex marriage has been
that nature created two sexes those
sexes were made to procreate and thus
human sexual relations
should be based on that assumption which
obviously leads to
male female reproduction and male female
sexual relations
within the context of marriage there's
been a long-standing church position
there's nothing immoral or amoral about
it
it is a natural opposition well now the
white house is coming out and saying
that
that the white house disagrees with the
church's stance
despite the fact that joe biden
considers himself a devout catholic he
disagrees with the pope on this well let
me just tell you something
joe biden is not a devout catholic if by
devout catholic you mean he agrees with
church doctrine
which is usually the way that you define
people being devout in a particular
faith
is that they agree with the core
doctrines if you say i'm a devout jew
but also i don't agree with the sabbath
you're not a devout jew major is not you
can identify as
jewish thinking you can be of jewish
ethnicity but you're not a devout jew if
you just reject the sabbath outright
and it's hard to be a devout catholic if
you just reject church doctrine on court
issues like abortion and same-sex
marriage
but again this is all part and parcel of
a broader leftist attack on institutions
so speaking of those broader leftist
attacks on institutions
don lemon of cnn is very angry at the
vatican today
so number one i don't think that don
lemon is a great source on catholicism
like if you are looking for your source
on catholicism i typically would not go
to the guy who was essentially doing
wolf calls
at waiters according i think he was a
new york magazine profile of don lemon
he was wolf calling and and and
assessing the the sexual attributes of
male waiters during an actual sit-down
interview
this was considered charming at the time
right that's the way this works
don lemon though has some thoughts on
catholicism in the vatican
why do why is why
just why and the answer is because of
course he's left-wing
and the left will not rest until the
catholic church is wiped out of
existence
or hijack for liberation theology and
they get rid of their social policy
everything must mirror the left the left
cannot stand that anyone thinks
differently than they do
here is don lemon listen i respect
people's
right to believe in whatever they want
to know you know their god but if you
believe in something that
hurts another person that or that does
not give someone
the same rights or freedoms not
necessarily under the constitution
because this is
under god i i think that that's wrong
and i think that the
the catholic church and many other
churches really need to re-examine
themselves and their teachings because
that is not what god
is about god is not about hindering
people or even judging people
god is not about judging people that's a
new one
uh i'm not gonna take lessons on god
from don lemon
first of all anybody who tells you that
god is not about judging people is an
abject
that is literally one of god's roles
that is like the chief role when it
comes to humankind is judging people
that read a bible the notion that god
doesn't judge people
then what is the purpose of him just say
you're
just say that you're an atheist just say
that you don't believe in a god that
actually
cares about humanity if god cares about
humanity then god judges humanity
this has been a long-standing part of
religion every major religion
every single one that believes in a
monotheistic god believes that god
judges
people but again only the religion of
leftism says that we we're not
judgmental except that you're a moral
i mean the number of self-contradictory
statements there from don lemon is truly
incredible
he says i respect anybody's right to
believe what they want religiously
except if they believe that you know
things i disagree with like god judges
people and has standards for human
behavior
if they believe that then they're bad
people and immoral and they need to
rethink their teachings
listen i don't think that don lemon
needs to rethink his beliefs about
homosexual activity
it's a free country he can think
whatever he wants in fact
it's a free country and as long as he's
not harming anybody else he can act
however he wants
but guess what he doesn't get to dictate
to me how i lead my life or how i teach
my kids or what i believe
i thought that was the basic line that
was the basic agreement was it not
but no that is not the agreement because
when self-expression becomes key
institutions must die when
self-expression and self-identity become
key
institutions must die we have now
entered the
expressive individualism phase of
american life where all of society is
supposed to comply
with your view of yourself and if i
refuse to comply with that view i have
done you a harm now i've never done don
lemon harm
i haven't i haven't told him what he
cannot and can and can and
cannot do by law i have not said that
the government should impose in his life
in any way of which i am aware
none of that right he is free to engage
in whatever he wants to engage in so
long as it does not harm another human
being
okay but i am fully free to say that i
believe that he engages in sinful
activity
i am fully free to do that without that
constituting a harm but if you're an
expressive individualist if you believe
that the chief goal of happiness is to
define yourself without regard to what
others believe
but others have to mirror your own self
belief this is how you end up with a two
thousand year old institution called the
catholic church needs to be destroyed
because i don lemon have hurt feelings
right all of religion has to change
because my god doesn't
my view of god doesn't comport with
traditional religious views and my view
of god
says that everything i do ever is right
and because my view of god says that
if you believe that god does not think
that that is right this means that you
are intolerant and bad
so again the the one of the things that
you're seeing here from the left
on a broader religious level here is the
attempt to impute
bigotry to people who have religious
beliefs rooted in natural law
and the attempt to impute emotivism to
your political opposition emotivism is a
term coined by aleister mcintyre the
catholic theologian
i believe he uh teaches over university
of notre dame and uh
and aleister mcintyre who wrote a great
book called the after virtue that is
totally worth the read he talks about
emotivism
as one of the chief mechanisms of
american society at this point
is that we don't actually we don't
believe
that people's arguments come from a
place of logic and reason we believe
that people's arguments
come from a place of emotional uh of
emotionality
and because we believe that it is easy
to attribute to somebody who has a
different belief
some form of animus and that's what you
see from don lemon right there
he can't credit people who disagree with
him on the nature of sin with a
different premise on what god does and
what god is for
and what is to be derived from nature
and natural law he can't do that
instead it comes from bigotry and you
have to redo your entire church
to comply with don lemon's view of god
so that he feels better about himself
in fact don lemon has other thoughts on
jesus did you know this so he has
thoughts
on god apparently god exists
but is non-judgmental and is basically
just your high school diversity advisor
that's who god is god is just a being
who created you to do whatever the hell
you want without any level of judgment
and without any requirements for your
behavior
which means that he's utterly irrelevant
there is no reason to have god if that
is what you believe
and then don lemon also believes that
the way to cure american racism
is to teach that jesus wasn't white man
sunday school lessons with don lemon are
weird
i got to tell you this is a weird sunday
school with don lemon
we also have to start uh being realistic
about god
and the bible and if you are a person of
faith in this country
and you we know america is built on
faith and religious freedom
then we have to i think a good way of
starting
is to present the true identity of jesus
and that is as a black or a brown person
rather than someone who looks like a
white hippie from
uh sweden or norway then we can come to
a true
reality about what america really is
and then try to figure out how we fix it
this issue of racism in the country
um i have a question what in the actual
f is he talking about
like seriously what is he talking about
everyone knows
who has studied the bible that jesus was
not in fact
of nordic persuasion jesus was a jew
right he was from judea he was a jew
okay he probably looked like my
father-in-law who's from morocco
he was not a black person if by black
you mean he was african
no that no that is not true
so no on that also every single person
who has ever read
the new testament understands that jesus
was jewish it's one of the fundamental
bases
of the new testament is that jesus was a
jew
okay anybody who who believes that jesus
was not a jew is just ignoring the text
of the new testament
just ignoring it straight out so i'm
pretty sure that
everyone kind of knows that jesus was a
jew
and you know what that mean and by the
way what in the world
does the perspective on traditional
values have to do with the racial
identity
of jesus he can't explain this so
we are now in in a world in which god is
the golden calf
right this is what's truly amazing is
that people like don lemon
talking about god here god is just the
golden calf so if you read the bible if
you read the book of exodus
then the people when moses goes up on
the mountain the second time he goes up
back up on the man he goes for 40 days
it's a pretty good story also i'll tell
it god go
moses goes back on the mountain for 40
days after having given the 10
commandments
with with god's help or rather the other
way around god gives the ten
commandments with moses himself so moses
goes back up the mountain for 40 days he
stays too long and the people
downstairs get upset and they get angry
and they're not sure where the leader
went and so they decide to erect a
golden calf
right they go to aaron who is moses's
brother and they say we need a golden
calf to lead us now
and so aaron who's afraid that they're
going to kill him he says give me all
your gold and he throws the gold into
the fire and out comes the golden calf
okay the golden calf is bad it's bad
right the golden calf is a
representation of the idea that human
beings are apt to create their own gods
and those gods are apt to be reflective
of them because
when people create their own moral
standards and then attribute that to god
that is a
that is a deep deep sin to pretend that
god agrees with you rather than you
agreeing with god
is in fact to make a mockery of god
in fact my friend dennis prager this is
his entire take on the commandment in
the bible bible that you're not allowed
to take the lord's name in vain
he says that god really doesn't care if
you say gd what god really cares about
is the idea that you are taking your own
opinion then attributing it to god
but this is what don lemon is doing now
right he is saying
that he gets to define who jesus was he
gets to define who god was and if his
definition does not meet with the
bible's definition the bible's wrong
the vatican's wrong you see all of these
institutions are wrong traditional
institutions are wrong
they must be torn down on behalf of our
golden calf and our golden calf is our
own values
so take a backseat sit down your values
don't matter any longer and by the way
joe biden agrees with this devout
catholic tribe agrees with us
because joe biden says that he is a
devout catholic but also
disagrees with fundamental catholic
doctrinal points he's not even doing the
mario cuomo idea where mario cuomo
suggested
that this was his original formulation
that he was not a personal believer in
abortion but he didn't want to use
american law to cram that down
i think it's a bad political argument
when it comes to the protection of human
life
but at least you can see the division
there i personally in my life
believe x and i abide by the doctrine of
the catholic church but i don't believe
that that ought to be imposed at the top
level
right as an orthodox jew believe the
same thing i believe in the sabbath i
don't think it's the government's job to
force everybody to comply with the
sabbath
okay but that is not what joe biden is
claiming right joe biden says he does
not agree on same-sex marriage he does
not agree on abortion
but he's a devout catholic that's a form
of idolatry what don lemon is doing here
is a form of idolatry the entire left
leftist ideology is idolatry it is the
it is the positioning of a god that is
other
than actual monotheistic judeo-christian
god
and by the way even judeo-christian
islamic god right it's it's a
an entirely different concept of what
god is god is just your friend who's
supposed to pat you on the shoulder
until you did a good job no matter what
you did
god is your high school guidance
counselor and a gumball machine by the
way because you ask something of god and
he doesn't and he doesn't give it to you
then that's because god is bad it's not
your fault it's not that you ever have
to change
that is a recipe for complete
institutional collapse the left knows
this which is why they are pushing it
okay that's why the attack on the
vatican matters not because i think that
i give a damn what don lemon actually
thinks of religion but because it is
indicative of a broader
left-wing assault on religion as in as
as in outgrowth of the animus
as an outgrowth of bigotry it is why
it's such a mistake for folks on the
right
not to argue in terms of natural law not
to argue in terms
of personal happiness or what identity
actually constitutes and instead sort of
do this rear guard action
where the right doesn't defend its own
religious precepts instead they're like
yeah just leave us alone and we have the
right to do what we want to do
that all of that is true but they're not
going to leave you alone so you're going
to have to argue for the value of your
own positions
you're going to have to explain why your
positions are correct why there is
natural law to back them
the left is intolerant and they will not
leave you alone if you're a religious
person and you have shied away from the
fight
if you're a religious person you think
okay i'm just going to lead my life and
they'll leave their
they'll leave their lives and everyone
will be fine with each other no they're
going to make you bake the cake
they're going to make you mirror their
own beliefs and they're going to declare
that you are godless
if you don't do what they want you to do
they're going to declare that all these
institutions have to be torn down
and what do you get for going along with
them all you get for going along with
them is a temporary reprieve
because next time they disagree with you
on something they'll tell you they'll
tear you down
right over again they'll just do it
right again alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon the matt wall
show airing 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show